Yes, I wear makeup pretty much every day around my husband.
And here's why.
Back when I was single and I would go on dates,
I would get already right.
I would put on makeup,
I would do my hair,
I would spray on some perfume.
I would want to present my best to the guys I was going on dates with.
So I figured that if those guys,
those random guys that I wasn't even committed to,
that weren't committed to me,
that were just taking me on a date,
if they got to see the best side of me,
the most put together side of me,
should my husband,
who loves me and who I love and who has done so much for me,
shouldn't he get to see that side of me, too?
And obviously,
I don't think he even really cares.
Like, I could wear no makeup,
he'd be perfectly happy.
I do think it's more of like, a mentality thing.
Just personally, for me,
it's a way for me to remember how much he means to me
and how important he is to me
and how much I wished when I was single
that someone like him would come along.
And now that I have him,
I just like staying in that kind of mode.
And obviously, that has a lot to do, too,
with my attitude and my personality.
You don't go on a date with someone and nag them the whole time.
And So I really do try.
When he comes home from work
and when we're together on the weekends and stuff,
I try to be pleasant.
And sometimes that doesn't just come naturally.
Sometimes it's something that you need to do very consciously.
And so for me,
just to get into that mindset and get into that way of thinking,
I like to get ready,
I like to do my makeup,
I like to do my hair and try and just get into that mode of, like,
I'm in love with this guy,
you know? And we've been married for 10 years now,
and I have tried to do that most of the time we've been married.
Obviously, like,
I've had kids and I've been sick, and he's seen me at my lowest,
obviously. But
I have found that it is something that really helps me
put the most into our marriage.
And it is just honestly fun.
I like doing it.
It's fun. So if you're kind of in a rut and you kind of just wanna, like,
not necessarily,
like, spice things up,
but you want to be a better wife,
you wanna be a better spouse,
you wanna be a better partner,
I recommend getting ready,
doing some makeup,
putting on a cute outfit before you see your husband.
It's worked really well for us.